today's guest is a practicing physician
uh he's an author um and he's a
researcher into the phenomenon of
near-death experiences he has done the
largest case study over 5,000 cases of
uh near-death experiences and he wrote
the book evidence of the afterlife the
science of near-death experiences which
is a New York Times best seller um I'm
just I'm grateful to be able to spend
time with him today and uh and get to
learn about what's right on the cusp of
the afterlife today's guest is Dr
Jeffrey
long on
[Music]
me I'll sit and tell you my
story
shine on
me and I will find song
sing
I'm sitting here with uh yeah with Dr
Jeffrey long and uh you had the New York
Times bestseller like you were just
saying the evidence of the afterlife the
science of near-death experiences and
that term is fascinating to people you
know you hear near death It's like
because that's what we're everybody's so
afraid of that line that you know it's
and the finality of it um I want to
start just by asking what is what
quantifies near-death experience sure
now different researchers have different
concepts but the research definition
that I've always used is exactly what
the name implies you're near death in
other words you're so physically
compromised you're unconscious or you
may be clinically Dead with absent
heartbeat okay now at that time it
should be impossible to have any Lucid
conscious remembrance and yet people do
have that remembrance at that time and
that's the experience part of a
near-death experience okay and why is it
at that time time that you shouldn't be
able to have any Lucid like brain
activity why is that sure let's talk
about what happens to the brain after a
cardiac arrest which means the heart
stops beating okay the moment the heart
stops beating Theo obviously blood
immediately stops flowing to the brain
10 to 20 seconds after that event the
EEG which is Electro inogram a measure
of brain electrical activity goes
absolutely flat there's no measurable
cortical brain activ 20 seconds after
the heart stop after the heart stop and
after blood stops going to the brain it
should be impossible to have any
remembrance at that time let alone the
highly lucid and organized near-death
experience so you started to kind of
quantify or collect the experiences
people were having at that point
absolutely okay I've been researching
and Gathering near-death experiences for
over 25 years okay I was so fascinated
when I first heard about near-death
experience
that I really wanted to study them but
with the best methodology possible okay
and that being people that actually had
near-death experiences sharing their
firsters experience right so over 25
years ago I established the near-death
experience Research Foundation a
research website which encouraged people
to share a narrative of their experience
but also had a scientifically designed
huge number of questions actually as a
survey so that not only were we getting
large numbers of near death experiences
but we were learning about them from all
those survey questions at a depth that
heret for had been impossible okay so
you create a website where people would
go that had had near-death experiences
and they would start to just list out
the information write like what were
kind of some of the questions that would
be that you would ask to somebody sure
well first of course we have them give
The Narrative of their experience we
don't want any leading questions prior
to that time but then once we start and
currently the website survey has over 80
different questions some of the
questions include the leading research
tool called the nde scale which is a
series of 16 questions that are sort of
different in degrees of expressing that
particular element or or not expressing
it at all but in addition to that we
have dozens of other questions that help
establish basically demographic
questions male female where do you live
when did The Experience occur uh also
content questions which is very strong
focus of the survey and then finally
importantly After Effects how did their
life change after that how did their
life change in response to that amazing
near-death experience wow so 25 years
ago you start the website people start
reporting What's happen and they start
you start collecting this data were you
surprised at the number of people were
you like yeah what are some things that
kind of shocked you out of the gate
right off the bat I realized there was
overwhelming consistency even in the
first few dozen near-death experience
experiences I saw everything I knew as a
physician told me this is not possible
you can't have highly Lucid conscious
experiences when you're unconscious or
or clinically dead and yet here the very
first few dozens of people sharing with
me very clearly and what was very
impressive is the remarkable consistency
of the elements they were describing
what happened during the experience the
elements or if you will characteristics
okay not only were they very
consistently seen across many many
near-death experiences but they
typically occurred in a very consistent
and logical order this is nothing like
dreams or hallucinations or any other
type of pathologically altered
Consciousness I realized very very
quickly and as I was to learn uh even
more and more with it got more and more
experiences shared with me near-death
experiences are in a word real yeah what
were some of the things that made you
that led you to believe that they were
real oh absolutely the overwhelming
consistency now while no two near-death
experiences are the same if you study a
lot of them them and Theo I've studied
over 4,000 oh wow so with that huge data
set around there it's kept me busy it's
my second full-time job wow St Peter
over here Milling around it yeah it's
tough to be a full-time doctor which I'm
trying to do while while doing that is
my other full-time job but what I have
observed and and other near-death
experience researchers see is that very
consistent pattern of what happens when
you have a near-death experience well of
course there's that lifethreatening
event they're unconscious or clinically
dead no heartbeat but at that time a
very common first element is what's
called an out of- Body Experience okay
Consciousness separates from the
physical body and goes above the body
now from that vantage point they can see
ongoing Earthly events often including
people frantically trying to bring them
back to life they may then go into or
through a tunnel variably described
often at the end of the tunnel there's a
beautiful unearthly they emphasize light
in that after passing through the tunnel
then at that time they may be in an
unearthly what some call a Heavenly
realm aptly described it's very
different from what we've known
everywhere on our Earthly life it's
literally a non-physical realm movement
is non-physical communication is
essentially always telepathic uh time is
almost invariably described as either
radically different from Earthly time or
not existing at all in this realm this
unearthly beautiful heavenly realm there
can be encounters with deceased loved
ones there can be a review of a part or
all of their prior life called a Life
review at this point they can be uh
colors like in plants and and Landscape
that are so beautiful that there are no
earthly words that they have to describe
them there can be buildings around this
time there's often a decision that they
make as they interact with other beings
about whether to stay in this beautiful
unearthly realm or return to their
Earthly life and that body struggling to
survive okay so those are the most
common characteristics of of the
near-death experiences and what's what
what would be like the your strongest
evidence that this actually happens
because anybody can kind of go on a
website you know any naysay like anybody
can go on a website and fill it out
right sure there's been a ton of people
that have done it but like what's the
most common evidence that that you
believe that this has happened that you
believe oh absolutely you know Theo we
talked earlier about that outof body
experience where Consciousness goes
above the body above the unconscious or
k to's physical body below what I and
other researchers have investigated is
how accurate are those observations in
that out of body State and amazingly in
my study over 98% of what people are
seeing and hearing with their physical
body and conscious down below is
accurate down to the finest detail and
in fact they can make these observations
in that outof body State geographically
far from their physical body far outside
of any possible physical sensory
awareness for example what do you mean
when you say that just before you get to
the example like geograph like what do
you I'm a little sorry I got confused
there yeah let me give you an example
what I'm talking about we had one
relatively recent near-death experience
lady was riding a horse and was out you
know basically breaking in the horse and
the horse threw her off and she hit her
head very severe head injury immediately
unconscious she had that out of- Body
Experience Consciousness above her body
saw her body lying on the ground saw the
horse heading back to home home but then
her Consciousness went to where she had
started prior her journey the barn and
she was able to hear other people
talking aware of what they were saying
doing they didn't know that she was
fighting for her life over a mile away
because they weren't aware of that they
only were aware of that when the horse
arrived without her and again she was
able to see and bring back all that
information verified down to the finest
details of what she was seeing and a
mile away obviously there's no way
you're going to see here or perceive in
any way with your normal sensory
function and so that's a common thing
people like so hovering kind of outside
of themselves so people leaving their
Physical Realm right you leave you es
and I guess do they
feel okay being away from themselves do
they feel like Jeepers I got to get back
into myself like when you lost your
phone or something you know or does it
feel like that's what I would be like
gosh because if I'm just Milling around
it's almost like you're just naked like
you're as naked as you could be you're
naked down to your soul you you know
that's a good assumption and I kind of
wondered about that too early in my
research but amazingly even though these
people are unconscious or clinically
dead and may have had you know severe
trauma or illness problems that led to
that episode of unconsciousness when
that Consciousness separates from their
physical body they essentially never
describe any pain it's unusual for them
to feel fear about Consciousness apart
from their body far more commonly
described is a sense of calm a sense of
Peace a sense amazingly that this is
actually their real conscious self that
being non-physical and apart from their
body down below ah so that's a common
thing that people say oh this felt that
felt a lot more real than the existence
I'd been having in my body oh absolutely
in fact we have a survey question and we
ask people you know about what they said
said what they old decided about the
reality of their experience and in our
survey of 834 people that had a
near-death experience where we asked
that question 93.8% said their
experience was definitely real and over
and over as part of that they were
saying it was more real than anything
they'd known in their Earthly life they
typically have acceleration of
Consciousness uh amazingly the
substantial majority even though they're
physically unconscious or clinically
dead are actually thinking process at a
speed they simply couldn't have done in
their Earthly life Wow a good example of
that is we talk briefly about the Life
review I mean just imagine that here you
are unconscious or clinically dead and
yet about a fifth of people have a Life
review or they may see part or even all
of their prior life here they are
unconscious just for often minutes
certainly you know less than to 30
minutes almost always and yet at that
time they're re reliving viewing all
that went on in their prior life an
amazing demonstration of just how rapid
Consciousness can be during a near-death
experience so that's one you said one
out of five people had that yeah Life
review okay and a Life review yeah I
mean I think that makes sense because
the brain is like the the ultimate
function of the brain is to
organize and um and I feel like a lot of
times I guess it would make sense if you
if you're brain is worried that it's
going to shut down it's still trying
to like it would almost show it almost
seems like say if it's trying to prove
at the last second hey what but what
I've been doing makes sense here's my
work it's almost like you're trying to
show your professor like look I have the
beginning I have the next I have this I
have this doesn't this check out cuz
does that make any sense thinking like
that absolutely that's how I thought for
a long time going into my near-death
experience research absolutely I assumed
as I think most people would rationally
assume that near-death experiences had
to be due to physical brain function
because Theo that's how we think that's
how we live our life I mean that's what
we're used to we haven't really in
general had any particular experience of
Consciousness or awareness that wasn't
part of our physical brain but that is
the amazing thing about near-death
experiences during the Life review it's
not a matter of them using their
physical brain it's like that
Consciousness apart from the body where
they're seeing and hearing things Theo
you can't possibly do that with normal
physical sensory awareness and in fact
we have scores and scores of near-death
experiences that had their
life-threatening event typically
typically their heart stopping while
they were under general anesthesia now
under that blanket of sleep it should be
and as many of you know that have been
under general anesthesia I mean the
brain just shuts off there's no possible
remembrance at all and at that time
they're carefully monitoring vital signs
I know I've been there I'm a doctor I've
you know seen do people wake up and say
something racial sometimes I've done
that before is that crazy I've never I
can honestly say I I haven't ever done
I've heard I've heard of people waking
up and and having their with altered
brain some bizarre conversations with
the anesthesia team and ask any
anesthesiologist they'll have all sorts
of stories like that by the way is a bit
of an aside but getting back to that uh
Cardiac Arrest heart stopping while
under general anesthesia Theo it should
be doubly impossible for the physical
brain to produce any kind of awareness
or experience and yet from from being
under anesthesia it it should be
completely impossible scientifically for
the brain to recall anything absolutely
and yet at that time by the scores me
and other near-death experience
researchers are finding that they do
have near-death experiences typical
near-death experiences like all others
okay so that is if you will doubly
impossible that that could be due to the
physical brain function so okay so but
what's how do you know something is not
just a dream how do you or I'm trying to
think of another word for a dream but I
don't know another word for it yeah well
that's a good one I mean in all of our
lives we typically have dreams that's
very common near-death experiences are
nothing like dreams Theo at the risk of
embarrassment I'm going to share you how
with you how I found out about that at
the very dawn of putting a survey up on
the website I asked the question was
your experience dreamlike in any way and
oh I was embarrassed at the responses no
way no chance absolutely not uh emphatic
over and over again for people having
near-death experiences emphasizing this
had nothing to do with dream so I I
quickly let go of that line of
questioning so again you know when you
hear about a near-death experience it
seems so unearthly people normally would
think gosh isn't that like a dream that
I'm familiar with yeah nothing
absolutely nothing like a dream it's far
more lucid and conscious the a dream
Theo typically events May skip around in
a illogical order yeah it's almost like
that movie gum o con you ever seen that
I've heard of it yeah I haven't seen it
yeah it's like yeah it's I mean it's
it is what it is but yeah it's like
somebody it's it's like it's like
somebody made a collage dreams are feel
like a collage I love that that's a
great way to look at it uh it you're
typically less Lucid less conscious than
Earthly everyday life uh events in the
dreams skip around because well they're
like dreams you're hanging with your
buddy then you got a snake and then you
look inside of a window and then
everybody hates you you know and then
you have to go home because you did
something I love we've all been there
Theo so you're right that's nothing like
near-death experiences while it's a a
different type of of altered
Consciousness it's actually a hyper
Lucid Consciousness it's interesting
when you say that because like whenever
I so and I I don't want to like just
equate this to iasa right but I'd done
drugs in my life you know and you know
have you ever done any uh no say
anything no I I I actually haven't you
haven't yeah no oh um yeah and that's
okay right and some people do them and
some people don't and but when I went
and did I
it was not like doing a drug people were
like do you get messed up you know it's
like no dude it is a
intense
emotional boot camp where like
you're like you
almost your thoughts suddenly
have a a response to them in a way like
suddenly your like the world thinks back
at you that's what it feels like kind of
never really was able to think about it
but the world you can feel the world
literally thinking back at you and
reflecting so you get so much there's a
lot of um uh like solving of problems
because you're not just wondering and
putting things out in there and waiting
for you to solve them it feels like
nature or the world or God or a higher
entity or a collective entity or energy
meets you halfway and helps you work
like in real time and it's a very loving
helpful um entity or energy even though
it can take you through some moments
that feel challenging it feels like
extremely uh cathartic and helpful um so
that's one of the things that made me
fascinating when I started hearing about
uh some of your work I was like oh this
is so I wonder how much of this is
similar to some of the experience that I
had on IAS and I wonder what just what
people's experiences are like you know
well I can address that okay um I
co-authored a paper that was published
in the annals of the New York Academy of
Sciences and the lead researcher
investigated the published medical
literature about a wide variety of what
we call psychotropic or brain acting
drugs and looked at the descriptions of
these experiences and compared it to
near-death experiences and the
conclusion of this study really
radically different experiences between
psychotrop drugs and near-death
experiences but above and beyond that
Theo for anybody listening or viewing
this you can find out for yourself
there's a website called Arrowood
eid.org aroid aid.org has thousands of
firsters shared experiences with
psychotropic drugs it is amazing how
many they have you can look up any type
of psychotropic drug you can look up
iasa experiences arrow with EO e wi
documenting the complex relationship
between humans and psychoactives wow
uhhuh they have thousands of experience
it is by far the best resource for
anybody that would like to compare
near-death experiences and what happens
in near-death experiences with
psychotropic drugs go there you can look
up iasa you can look up DMT you can look
up LSD there are literally hundreds of
examples of virtually all of these
psychotropic drugs I've done that and
very quickly you'll realize as I have
and others do that go through that
exercise that the psychotropic drug
experiences from shared by people that
actually had them are in general
radically different for what happens in
a near-death experience they're more
hallucinatory they're more often
frightening they're more often dreamlike
in a sense that events can skip around
all you have to do is read 10 iasa
especially 20 iasa experiences from that
source and read 10 or 20 near-death
experiences and it jumps out at you
immediately the contrast and then
finally wow when we have our survey
people will often share when they have a
near-death experience that they've also
tried psychotropic drugs and in general
they will state from The Source people
that had both near-death experiences and
psychotropic drug experiences that the
two experiences are radically different
the near-death experience is grippingly
real the psychotropic drugs are tending
to be not real that's what you'd expect
with a hallucinatory experience damn
dude you make me want to I want to have
a damn near-death experience oh well I
tell you what it's and I want to
emphasize that me a lot of people hear
about the near-death experiences and go
wow I got to go get me some of that and
we I have to give a I'm going to give a
cautionary note to you and I think this
is important uh some people hear about
near-death experiences and and
tragically a few people will actually do
something risky with their lives you
know up to even considering suicide and
I think is I want to emphasize that
people that have had near-death
experiences as a result of suicide
attempts learn almost uniformly during
their near-death experience that that
suicide attempt was a huge mistake
virtually everyone that has a near-death
experience as a result of an effort at
suicide and then recovers will Almost
Never attempt suicide again and why
because they understand life is
Meaningful life is important they're
here for a reason even if their life is
extraordinarily difficult and by the way
if you if you commit suicide and don't
have a near-death experience you're much
more likely unfortunately to attempt
suicide again at some future time wow
really yeah yeah well also if you're
listening you didn't commit suicide
that's a good point you know like not no
no judgment to anybody that gave it a
run or whatever you know we're glad
you're no good at it okay that's good
but yeah you didn't do it did people
that tried suicide did a lot of them
have near-death experiences well I guess
they did because they tried suicide but
that's a physical act of it well I and
that's a good question Theo first of all
I want to point out that of people that
have a life-threatening event only about
10 to 20% of them will actually have a
near-death experience 80 or 90% don't so
you're saying if somebody falls off a
cliff somebody you know falls into like
a um butter churner or something or
somebody gets hacked by somebody
somebody gets beaten hit by train
whatever domestic dispute heavy domestic
dispute and something happens to him
you're saying only a small percentage of
those will have then within their
unconsciousness then have a near-death
experience right does it matter how you
get into unconsciousness on whether or
not you have a near-death experience no
it doesn't make any difference what that
life-threatening event was as to whether
you have a near-death experience in fact
the only good research study found the
closer to death you are the more likely
you are to have a near-death experience
wow so you got to walk over there huh
yeah it's kind of interesting I I
actually feel I actually co-authored a
scholarly book book chapter where we
looked at all the demographics I mean
you name it you know gender location
what led to the near-death experience
and we could find no correlation with
what the life-threatening event was what
your demographic background was didn't
really seem to predict the probability
of having a near-death experience when
you nearly die nor what the content
would be so you're saying yeah cuz I
would think some ethnicities and I you
know and probably like I'm not going to
you know
but people in like Memphis or something
might be more likely to have near-death
experiences because there's more near
death going on you know what I'm saying
like but you didn't find that any
ethnicities or genders or anything or
ages had none were more likely to have
near-death experiences than others yeah
absolutely not there was some earlier
research the thought maybe children were
more likely to have a near-death
experience when they nearly died but I'm
not seeing that so it seems to be you
know interestingly Theo I me well
children just came from Life they just
came from life so you think like oh they
might have maybe just they got a shorter
tether well yeah and I think so you know
they'd be less likely to but on the
other hand Theo I studied very young
children age five and and below average
age of the study group was three and a
half years old now at that very young
age when they had their near-death
experience they're practically a
cultural Blank Slate they almost
certainly have no formed ideas about
religion the afterlife they almost
certainly have never heard of what
near-death experience is or wouldn't
understand it if they had and yet these
people statistically had basically
exactly the same content the elements of
near-death experience as older children
and adult which is a very strong line of
evidence that pre-existing beliefs don't
really lead to people you know having a
near-death experience or what the
content of the near-death experience is
wow that's fascinating so whether it was
a 90-year-old or a seven-year-old that
seemed to articulate well you found that
the that what they shared was had a lot
of similarities yeah absolutely that's
that's really and that's exciting
because you know it seems it gives you
some proof that you're on to something
that you know it just furthers your your
belief well it really uh eliminates the
skeptic concern that the near-death
experiences are pre-existing beliefs
it's what they thought would happen and
there's there's absolutely right cuz a
child doesn't really have enough time to
have too much of a pre-existing belief
exactly you wouldn't think exactly
man I've been so dehydrated from flying
around from um sweating from letting
fluid out of my body you will be
dehydrated baby and liquid IV helps gosh
it'll turn water just in a just in just
a beautiful nectar that just fills you
up it really will with three times the
electrolytes of the leading sports drink
plus eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness liquid IV hydrates two
two times faster than water alone all in
a single sugar-free stick I've had it
the flavors are remarkable they got one
of them is called White Lime or
something or what is it dang white peach
or something God I love that one
rehydrate yourself in this new year grab
your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugarfree in bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20% off your first order when you
go to liquid
i.com and use code Theo at checkout
that's 20% off your first order when you
shop better hydration today using promo
code Theo at liquid iv.com the new year
for many people means uh finding out
ways to save some money you know what
I'm talking about some women will uh
start cutting their husband's hair a lot
around this time of year and they saving
money but the husband has to look kind
of bad or
whatever but after the holidays we we
could all use a little cash in our
pockets that's why ibata is here to help
ibata is a free app that gives you the
most cash back every time you shop on
hundreds of items from groceries to
Beauty Supplies to toys who don't want a
toy so you can make sure you're beating
inflation no matter what you're
purchasing the average ibata user earns
$145 per year that's right and right now
I bought i b o
TTA is offering our listeners
$5 Just For Trying ibata by using Code
Theo when you register just go to the
app store or Google Play Store and
download the free ibata app to start
earning cash back and use code Theo
that's ibata in the Google Play or App
Store and use code
Theo one thing that I found that was
really interesting that really made me
lock in and want to learn more was when
you said that people of different
religious beliefs and things like that
and they all none of them they all had
the same uh there was they had the same
characteristics of their experience if
they had a near-death experience that
you're exactly right the really sh I was
like wow so there's that anyway yeah
that's one of the things that really
hooked me in yeah and and that's exactly
right in my research we've had well the
website our research website has been
translated into over 30 different
languages so as a result we can do by
far the largest cross cultur stud do
that CU otherwise if you get like yeah
you get some dude yeah you get some guy
fresh out the bario or something and
he's like you know we was dreaming you
know like hold on bro yeah and and
that's that's what's exciting when you
have pull in near-death experiences
literally from all around the world in
their native language so we have about
60 what we call non-western near-death
experiences these are in countries where
they're not predominantly
judeo-christian and they're from just
you name the relig ious background I've
run into it and remarkably these
nonwestern near-death experiences the
content what occurs the the elements are
strikingly similar to typical Western
near-death experiences and in fact I've
co-authored a scholarly paper with an
Iranian near-death experience researcher
looked at a couple dozen people that had
near-death experiences in Iran exactly
what I'm seeing in my series no matter
where on Earth you have your near-death
experience amazingly it doesn't make any
difference Theo whether you're say a
Muslim in Egypt or a Hindu in India or a
Christian in the United States or no
religious belief at all wherever on the
planet you have your near-death
experience whatever age the content what
occurs is going to be strikingly similar
do you feel like over time though that
you became
uh what am I the term I look for like
you became that's what you started
looking for you know what I'm talking
about oh um I I what's the term I'm
about it's like yeah um uh confirmation
bias did you believe did
did you worry about that did you take
that into account at all oh absolutely
as as a researcher I have to carefully
minimize anything that would affect
wrongly my interpretation and
confirmation bias is one thing but
that's the glory of having the survey
and then archiving the results and then
posting them all Theo we have over 4,000
near-death experiences posted we have
scores of non-western near-death
experiences give me one of those that
was interesting that kind of really
surprised you was there is there one
that stands out like a non-western yeah
we have uh there was a a lady who was
literally dying of hodkin lymphoma oh
gosh and you know it tragically uh was
given basically no chance of survival
and right at death's door she had a
near-death experience a profoundly
detailed near-death experience and as
part of that she became aware that if
she was to choose to return to Earthly
life that the lab results that were just
drawn would come back showing she was
recovering she was starting to respond
and if she chose not to return to her
Earthly life that the lab results would
indicate she was on her path to
irreversible permanent death amazingly
she recovered and when she recovered she
had an amazing highly detailed
near-death experience with with most of
the characteristics we've talked about
now well see that's interesting is that
makes me think that some of the
information that you get or in a
near-death experience right
and I hate that we keep having to say
the term over and over again but we have
to say it we do we really do um what
some of the information that you get
during an experience like that I wonder
if some of it then because at first I'm
thinking it comes from the other side it
comes from the great beyond you know
that but then now I'm thinking that if
you're getting information where you see
that you may be getting lab results
coming that would be different if you
return that makes you wonder if some of
that information is somehow coming out
of your body like on this side
and service and you know well does that
make any sense Well normally you does
that make sense or not yeah it does
because you would have to say maybe you
have a personal deep down sense that
this is going to happen however if
that's the case then I would be thinking
that some of that near-death experience
is in is influenced on this side of
right life as opposed to what part of me
is was leaning towards it being
influenced on the other side of life
absolutely so you know it it's very
reasonable to H to hypothesize that
maybe something that occurs or cribed in
near-death experiences is just because
they had that sense that that inner
awareness in their physical body but
Theo their unconscious are clinically
dead when they have their near-death
experiences so they really can't gather
from that sense that memory um that
subconscious part of themselves because
everything is shut down when they have a
a near-death experience are there other
choices I know you mentioned early on
that people were there were choices that
people had to make so that one is a lady
saying lab results could make her or
upcoming live results could be different
were there other choices that came up
yeah I'll tell you the most poignant
choice that we encountered in near death
experiences and that is a choice to stay
in that unearthly beautiful realm uh in
the environment there in off Spirits or
the choice to return to their Earthly
life and struggle to overcome that
life-threatening event that they caused
the near-death
experience what is it and this is where
it gets really interesting Theo at that
moment of decision even though people
having the near-death experience
everything that they knew up to that
time friends family loved ones Decades
of their life often is their Earthly
life and yet what they're experiencing
in this unearthly realm overwhelming
sense of peace and love those are about
the two most common words used and they
often describe that they feel this
unearthly beautiful realm is their real
home home their true home but the great
majority of people that are in that
unearthly Heavenly realm that make a
decision they asked to make a decision
want to stay there they want to leave
their Earthly life and not come back and
believe me they uh that is a difficult
decision they will often argue with the
beings there you go to Destin for the
first time you've been in Des oh yeah so
that's that's really interesting to
leave there that's just how compelling
and beautiful and what the sense is like
in this unearthly beautiful realm that
they're in of near-death experiences wow
see and so that makes me believe that
it's not like iasa because in iasa and I
only compare to that because like I've
done you know some of the other
psychotropics LSD and uh and uh
mushrooms right and those the only ones
I've done I know there's a lot of new
ones and people are you know sucking on
animals or whatever and you know licking
frogs or whatever there's some stuff
hope not a lot Theo I mean I look I mean
I don't know look I know a dude has done
a thing down there you know a couple of
okay well that'll leave a taste in my
mouth but moving
on look I know a guy north of Panama
City I don't know if he's ever gotten
high but he's definitely done some
things okay goodness great um but on
iasa I never felt a sense of Peace it's
always a sense of um learning and
constant like uh nego not negotiating
but uh revealing and um catharsis but
not a big some relief but never feels
very much like you're in a long period
of uh therapy which sometimes can be
extremely intense so it doesn't feel
like you're in this um you know a
million thread count ex you know space
which that sounds like what you're
talking about wow yeah now
now is there a and if so people if they
some people might have near-death
experience but they just die and you're
like oh [__] we didn't get the
information oh absolutely I mean you
know at a life-threatening event you
know certainly unfortunately a lot of
people will ultimately permanently and
irreversibly die so that's uh you know
that that's it however U that brings up
an interesting point we do have a small
series of what we call shared near-death
experience these are two or more people
that simultaneously had a
life-threatening event no and true story
there we've got uh we're up to about 20
posted on the website so it's not not a
real small twins kind of so what happen
I mean you name it auto accidents
collapsing building you know some kind
of accident out in nature these are all
common precipitating events so two or
more people boom they're in that
life-threatening event in a shared
near-death experience they can interact
with each other they be aware of their
physical body down below in these shared
near-death experiences at least in the
series I have one goes on to permanently
irreversibly die the other returns back
to their body and and then when they
recover they can talk about a shared
near-death experience now Theo that is
some of the strongest evidence I can
conceive of that for those permanently
irreversibly dying What You observe in a
near-death experience is that initial
pathway but you're saying one of them
died and one of them didn't but if one
if one of them died then how do you know
that that person had the experience too
because the other person shared an
experience with them they talked they
interacted um they communicated so the
one that lived said that they both both
of them were together body experience
for example we had from Canada we had a
car bad car accident and a gentleman was
driving with his fiance boom car fell
asleep and hit a tree both him and his
fiance had that out of- Body Experience
holding hands I mean their fiance rose
up and then they were able to see this
unearthly beautiful realm in the
distance there were four beings that
came up to them two of them went to her
two of them them went to him and they
separated their holding hands they felt
so much peace and love they described he
wanted to say no but but felt so
compelling compellingly that's why it
was remarkable that he felt so much
peace and love that he didn't want to
resist it and so wow he watched the two
beings carry his fiance toward this
beautiful unearthly realm in the
distance the other two beings gently
lowered him back down to the car from
way above the car he saw the front end
on fire and then he went back into his
body and he felt when he returned to
Consciousness his fiance leaning on his
shoulder as she was when he had the
accident and he knew immediately fiance
was dead she was an empty shell and that
he had left her with those beings above
that's a shared near-death experience
and very dramatic shared near-death
experiences are that's unbelievable I
mean out of 4,000 you know it have maybe
about 20 that's how rare they are and
yet they're so dramatic in terms of
providing evidence that for those that
permanently irreversibly die their
Consciousness continues to live and will
eventually be reunited see that's so w
the fact that two people had it now was
there ever two people that had it and
both of them
lived uh there have been not in my
series we have U there has been a report
of firefighters they were called The Hot
Shots in Arizona and they were battling
a fire and the fire they perform
yeah then they wind changed Direction
and trapped them and so there were many
of the firefighters that died and
certainly all of them had a
life-threatening event and they were
aware of each other and then ultimately
came back to report that remarkable
shared near-death experiences where
several lived and several died
wow oh man that's I was that for food
for thought that those just blow me away
I mean I tell you even after 4,000
near-death experiences when I read these
shared near-death experiences I'm still
in awe even after 25 years can you tell
when somebody some are fake we are very
careful to investigate whether they're
fake Theo we ask many of our survey
questions in a similar concept we're
asking but worded differently in
different sections of the survey so as a
result we use that tried and trude
method to make sure that the near-death
experience responses are valid above and
beyond that is a doctor I can certainly
spot things that don't add up medically
but finally if the overwhelming majority
of people share true and honest
near-death experiences even those people
that share falsified near-death
experiences if they're that rare it
isn't really going to change our overall
understanding of what happens during a
near-death experience and what their
meaning is what are some things that
people do where that if they're telling
a fake near-death experience where you
can kind of spot those or some of the
because there's got to be commonalities
there too I'm sure the main well first
of all when we do our survey we always
post it anonymously they don't get paid
anything they literally have no public
recognition because they're experience
no real no incentive no incentive at all
right for them no Cloud at all no
direction for them to share a falsified
yeah no coughing cloud or whatever they
call it it it would take probably most
people especially with a detailed
account over an hour to fill that out
and so people generally aren't going to
do that just for laughs um so I think in
general and and certainly what we're
observing in our near-death experience
accounts are strikingly similar to what
all other researchers are finding in
their research Series so I'm reasonably
confident that these great great
majority of you not virtually all are
legitimate are legitimate yeah what are
what are is it mostly is it more women
that fill them out than than men because
women I think lowkey want to die all the
time I feel like
well because they love Date Line you
know what I'm saying they're always like
oh you know they're always leaving a
window open like that's a great question
it's probably pretty close to 5050 but
I'll tell you why I think Theo guys like
us are just a little more inclin than
women to drive the car fast to go do
risky things you know swim and places we
shouldn't swim we've all been I mean
it's a guy thing so we may be a little
more predisposed to have fun in some
risky way women I think are a little
less inclined to do that so I think that
may help explain why it's about 50 right
cuz you have more men that are actually
getting doing getting close with death
and accidents but you have more women
who may um share stories like that yeah
they're more inclined to share women
child birth and you know severe
complications and clinical death during
child birth we have a huge number of
those type of near-death experiences
have you ever had a woman that had a
child and then the child but I guess the
child would wouldn't be able to
recollect something like that yeah no we
don't have any uh if if a lady had a
near-death experience there's no you
know obviously they're they are very
good at delivering the baby even if she
has a life-threatening event but there's
no real discussion later from that child
of oh I had a shared near-death
experience I remember years later that
it would be yeah it'd be too hard to
remember what motivates you to care
about this I am fascinated by near-death
experiences even after 25 years and
4,000 near-death experi you been in Bush
Gardens yeah I have yeah that's awesome
too is that's that's true but I love all
that kind of stuff it's fun well
near-death experiences to me it it
continues to remind me that there's an
afterlife a wonderful afterlife and
that's for all of us I'm a physician
that treats patients with cancer these
are my patients that have
life-threatening events and I'm involved
with them every day what I know about
near-death experience has helped me to
help them in their Journey with their
battle with cancer in a way with more
courage more confidence that even if we
ultimately don't cure them that in the
end they're going to have a wonderful
afterlife and as I've told them you're
going to be in a much better place than
those left on our Earthly life so I
think that's really uh you know
certainly something to look forward to I
hope it I believe that too because even
just living is so like that's what I
always say when people are like I don't
believe in an
afterlife um I'm like all right
you know like first of all
what
like okay you know because here's why my
biggest proof is that we lived at all
yeah that's my like at least believe in
reincarnation because we already lived
yeah how you you then why then don't
even believe you're here then if you're
not even going to believe it's possible
that's that's ridiculous like I'm doing
this right now you're going to tell me
and I came out of nothing I don't know
where I was you know I got some vague
ideas is and you know I'll sketch some
stuff every now and then but I don't
have any real information but to think
this couldn't happen again to me seems
asinine it because you you have proof
like you're living in proof like it'd be
different if you weren't but you're
freaking living in proof that you that
existence from nothing is possible now I
know you came from people when you came
from sex but they eventually we don't
know where they came from mhm you know Y
and we don't know where life came from
that's the thing sure no I and
absolutely that's sorry to yell at you
or anything no this is great hey Theo
this is what I find among other things
very inspiring about near-death
experiences I mean here over and over is
very powerful evidence that we do have a
life after death our Consciousness goes
on we're not really going both for us
our friends our family our loved ones
when we have that final end of our
Earthly physical life there's a much
bigger picture a much we continuation of
consciousness uh Eternal and infinite as
best I can tell from near-death
experiences and that's exciting yeah I
mean whenever Earthly life can gets
miserable difficult and we've all been
there all of us and you always have that
that thought in the back of your mind
from near-death experiences wow here is
the evidence powerful evidence that we
go on well and it it makes me think like
you know we used to bring it back up
that aroid site was that aroid yeah e r
wi.
e r so if you'll zoom in on here the The
Vault of aroid and this was the site you
were talking where people share their
experiences from different psychedelic
techniques and methods yeah psychotropic
drugs uhhuh psychotropic drugs and it
also says on here there's breathing um
dreaming drumming fasting so it seems
like there's a lot of different like
modalities people used to get to diff
now maybe all these are un while they're
under the influence of psychedelic drugs
no I you know these are are obviously
different ways in which an altered
Consciousness can be achieved and that's
what's so cool about this site I mean
here are the original firstperson
accounts yes a lot like my own nf.org
website where there's really no they're
they're posted typically anonymously
there's no real incentive for them to
make any of this up these are people
that just want to share with the world
what happened during their experiences
often they're going to select out their
most dramatic interesting experiences
but it is a treasure Trove of Altered
States Of Consciousness yeah I love this
and so some of these on here are
somewhere it seems like it's not just uh
drug induced not just so psychotropic
that means drugs right okay so some of
these that has breathing dancing um
dreaming drumming uh fasting uh
meditation prayer Martial Arts yoga um
just as different modalities some I've
used of those breathing I I worked with
a a comedian this girl Blair SOI and she
does breath work and I had an experience
there that was um very uh it wasn't like
a near-death exper but it was beyond
something I'd ever had before where my
it locked up all of my muscles and I was
just with my um
some like way my conscience was you know
and that and it took a I remember just B
just tears coming out of me like it was
like uh a cleansing of some sort um
martial arts I've done MMA where at the
end of the class you s just sat there
and just like start crying because
you've done so much like just different
W your muscles and releasing things and
stuff and it um and I think a long time
ago they used to do a lot of sweating uh
a lot of meditation you know um
historically that's kind of what I was
getting at was like I wonder if there
was more connection with the afterlife
in previous centuries and ages of time
because they used uh less technological
modalities and more like uh actual
physical practicing of things you know
even if you go look at like the
Egyptians they would
draw and bury their dead sometimes with
tomb sometimes with tunnels that they
said would lead to another little tomb
that just had gifts of the afterlife
like they had just it feels like they
had a much more spiritual connection
maybe with with here and something
Beyond because they I mean to build a t
you know to build a tomb and to bury
somebody with all your worldly Goods
that you have to take all your money and
bury it with a friend so that they can
use it in the next realm it's you know
it's just a lot of that's really
fascinating cuz we don't practice a lot
of that anymore now somebody will slip
you a perk or slip you a thing of
cigarettes or something on the way you
know okay you know I'm so glad you
brought that up Theo does that make any
sense what I'm saying oh absolutely and
in fact I'll take that and run with it
near-death experiences as dramatic as
they are and as much as they point to
that afterlife they're really a subset
of that bigger picture just like what
you were talking about the umbrella is
spiritual experiences in general you
know absolutely you can have that type
of of spiritual experience with martial
arts I was a brown belt in karate I get
that I've walked a mile in those I can't
say shoes cuz we're barefoot yeah so uh
but on top of that you can have
certainly meditation experiences can
produce some dramatic experiences the
scholarly literature describes these as
mystical experiences okay and there's a
whole wealth of literature out there
about people that can have very dramatic
experiences uh sometimes they even
reproduce many of the characteristics of
near-death experiences and yet they're
all part of that if you will the
umbrella that bigger picture all
converging with evidence on the the fact
that there's Consciousness uh far beyond
what we're aware of in our Earthly life
that there's an afterlife there our
Consciousness is much more than just
what we think with how we interact with
other people uh our conscious Earthly
everyday experience that's just a subset
of a much bigger picture of
Consciousness just like what you were
saying yeah all of those things seem to
touch yeah they seem to find ways um I
don't know I just feel like historically
we probably even though now we're able
to catalog things better I mean back
then you had to draw it on a cave wall
or you had to whisper to your buddy you
know and if he gets damn you know you
know he comes across a rare STD on a
mountain top and it's you know nobody
knows what what happened and so it's
like you know just different times or
you know it just now we can catalog more
I feel like but the connction the
experience we have uh is kind of we have
less experiences maybe I don't know I
just it seems like our forefathers they
this was like a Saturday night they get
together in a sweat lodge and they
wanted to see something you know but it
was you had to you know make your own uh
Netflix in your in your brain yeah you
know I think you're right I think you're
really on to something there here's my
take on that I think years ago centuries
ago I think there was probably more
openness to these types of experiences I
think there was more um you know when we
didn't have that sort of scientific
rigidity about what the brain can do and
what it can't do I think people
collectively were more inclined to share
these stories to have people believe
them to Value them and as a result of
that allow them to be shared in a verbal
tradition probably much more so than we
have today because people were probably
less afraid to share that um these were
more tight-knit communities I mean they
knew each other they interacted with
each other and so I think there was more
trust that we have today today we're
sort of apart from each other more I
think it's harder to develop that
interpersonal trust perhaps as much as
existed centuries ago that's a shame
among many other reasons um people today
may be less inclined to share with
others their spiritual experiences
because they're afraid they'll be judged
yeah I want to let you know that the
best way to learn a language is
immersion that's right living where the
language is spoken and using it every
day
mm but if that's not in the cards this
year you can still learn a language the
second best way and that's with
Babble that's what I like to use don't
pay hundreds of dollars for private
tutors or waste hours on apps that don't
really help you speak the language
Babel's quick 10-minute lessons are
designed by over 150 language experts to
help you start speaking a new language
in as little as 3 weeks and here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners right now get 55% off your
Babel subscription but only for our
listeners at Babel
babbel.com
Theo get 55% off at babel.com
Theo spelled
babbel.com
t EO rules and restrictions May apply
and best of luck in in learning your new
language and that's really really
exciting
yeah or there's not as there's C well
it's interesting because there's it used
to be I mean sometimes you would be the
chief of a village if you had had like a
if you had gotten to you know connect
with the third eye you know it like
there was a lot of enhancement in and
um yeah there seemed to be a lot of more
of a social value to it I think we're
still going through this metamorphosis
maybe where you know we tried a lot of
uh medicines to cure people like a lot
of Western medicine that is proven to be
or slowly more and more proving to be
very much um not as helpful as we
thought more causing more addiction than
it is like probably benefits overall
maybe um and maybe I'm saying that to a
doctor maybe I shouldn't be but but that
we're getting more to where people are I
feel like we're trying to get back to
Nature and to finding ways to a take
care of ourselves better um um and then
B uh use other modalities to solve
particularly things that we struggle
with thinking and feeling wise than
medicine does that make any sense or not
oh I I think I see where you're going
with that Theo now more than ever we're
focused on we start with a focus on the
patient what's best for the patient well
prevention you know certainly um
treatments that have less toxicity very
strong focus in my specialty radi
oncology where we treat cancer we're
more interested in the totality of the
patient how are these treatments
affecting them how can we mitigate these
adverse effects how can we sort of
consider the patient totally mentally
physically spiritually and help be
everything that we can as health care
providers in a way that we perhaps
hadn't even thought about before so
there's a real it's kind of interesting
we're really kind of at a threshold now
where there's with a focus like that I
think we're I know we're we're curing
more people especially with cancer my
specialty than we ever did before but I
think importantly we're helping people
to live better than ever before because
we're so focused on the total patient
have there been experiences where you've
been able to discuss with cancer
patients who uh weren't fortunate enough
to to to get into remission that you
felt like talking about the afterlife
and possibilities and people's
experiences have been helpful to them oh
absolutely
uh of course I'm a well-known near-death
experience researcher so over and over
we have patients or their family members
Google who is this do Dr Long guy and oh
my gosh you know here's my hundreds of
times I've talked to the media and been
around and for people that are aware of
that they will generally come talk with
me about that next time they see me that
can be profoundly inspirational to
somebody who's got a life-threatening
illness they're in fear about that their
family their loved ones they know they
might not make it and yet here is the
research the information I have powerful
evidence that there is life after death
that there's a bigger picture for who we
are what we are that we're not just
physical brain function that we are a
Consciousness that's going to survive
our Earthly death it is incredibly
important to patients that come to that
understanding I've spent huge amounts of
time talking about that with patients
and I love that I consider that to be a
very special an important part of how I
practice medicine going in that extra
Dimension like that yeah well it's it's
just it's it's you know for one it's a
blessing that you care about this
because you're also in a in a in a field
where people are are walk
or are having to deal with death you
know sooner maybe than they expected um
do you ever have you ever been there
when somebody was passing away and just
kind of like like hey come on back you
know well yeah I mean I've done CPR for
real a few times and you know that I
tell you what that look around while
you're down
there the first thing they say in the
books is when you have it someone codes
or heart stops and you have to try to
bring them back from the brink check
your own pulse first too because you're
Ah that's pretty pretty Eerie why you
because you can freak out oh it's spooky
I mean your your heart rate I mean it's
Fredy when you have do CPR well when I
do it for real yeah when we brought
people I mean this is literally
unexpected typically it's life and death
um you know it's there we're we're
frantically trying to do the best I
would be worried like say if there's
house music playing in the place I would
be worried I would just what if you just
tap into it be you're like what is going
on dude come on no you Theo I just don't
want to be laying a James Blake track on
somebody you know like at least I mean I
can't speak for others but I'll tell you
when I've done CPR yeah you stay focused
and you want to make sure you're doing
just the right number of chest
compressions per saying you get some guy
like me in there and it's just you know
get out the way for cotton I Jo and just
playing that you know what I'm saying I
don't want you'd make an awesome doctor
I love that Theo we need to get because
that would be I haven't heard a doctor
ever share that but hey you know that's
I think I would be disbarred immediately
I'm just saying that like if you're not
really locked in on what you're doing if
you're doing CPR on somebody you know
and somebody just you know lays it lays
some kind of a track in the distance
anything can happen you know
have you ever had a near-death
experience no I haven't thank goodness
so now have you is there part of you
that because at some point you gotta you
know put your muffins where the oven is
you know what I'm saying bro like that
and like you know what I'm saying that
some point okay there people were going
to you know what I'm saying if you want
to write the third book you got to have
to go over there but let me tell you how
it works in the real world here Theo
people that have had a near-death
experience in general typically are not
near-death experience researchers and I
think the reason for that is they know
about near-death experience it is
grippingly real they understand it they
understand its implications in their
life and so as a result of that they're
not asking questions like me and so many
other people that do research in this
area that want to know is it real what
happens so again near-death experience
cures any near-death experience
disbelief that's for sure does part of
you ever wish like you know and it's not
nobody wants to cuz near death
experience you got a death is in the
middle of it that's the tricky part of
the rest of it you can handle but death
is the part you got to risk you know but
is any part of you ever like you
know where like oh where if you say you
ever been skiing and then you fall
you're like oh this could be it let's
see what happens here yeah I'll tell you
I have so many irons in the fire in my
life I've got a full-time Medical
Practice uh I love doing research and
sharing about near-death experience I've
got so much going on I'm very careful
not to get into a life-threatening event
I mean one you know I me I get where
you're coming from sure at one level it
would be I think an adjunct to my
research to say this is what I
experienced and here's what happened but
don't you think that might you get a
little confirmation bias and then I'd
start to see other near-death
experiences through the filter of my own
experience yeah dude I can't believe
earlier I was like we have a don't you
think there's a lot of confirmation bias
and then I just try to talk you into
confirmation bias well I yeah again when
I start my near-death experience
research my scientist coat goes on I
have to be very careful to use the best
scientific methods and avoid those kind
of pitfalls that are common in science I
mean you know that still science so
you're still applying science to
absolutely and I think that's one thing
that makes it more valid you know um we
had a guy Dr Max [__] do you know who
this guy is I I've heard the name I just
can't can't place it he is a he does the
um
he runs the uh what's it called where
they froze Walt Disney oh the cryogenics
oh yeah he's a he's like a um he's like
a philosopher he's like a futurist uh
he's a director of uh he's the he was a
CEO and a president of Alor life
extension and that's where they do like
cryonics and cryogenics where they
freeze people right so I I we talked
with him one time and I some people were
like oh this whole thing's a scam right
and and I looked at the financials of it
it it wouldn't really be worth it I
don't think if it were a scam it's it's
just not that much money it doesn't seem
like in it but it does seem like it's
just kind of there's there's just sort
of this blind hope that one day they
will be able to like
reincarnate or no to rehabilitate the
like the physical us that's here right
what are your thoughts on that like
because it's not really the same world
that you're in but there's there's this
the afterlife is part of you don't hear
much about the afterlife you know right
well you know Theo I'm as a researcher
and a scientist and as a physician I'm
interested in pretty much any aspects of
possible Survival Of Consciousness and
here we have groups that are freezing
bodies cryogenics hoping that people
will be able to be
resuscitated decades centuries from now
and literally be brought back to life
well a couple thoughts on that first of
all I I can't get over scientifically
the fact that when you freeze cells
human cells below 32° the water in the
cells expands boom it busts the cell
membranes and the cells are literally
dead how you can bring back completely
busted trashed if you will cells in an
entire living organism back to life is
is absolutely outside I know they're
using in liquid nitrogen to do it right
or something oh yeah that no that's cold
so that would be and I think they do it
at a quick enough level where they're
saying that that doesn't happen that de
composition doesn't happen that's what
their claimant is the ability to
suddenly freeze an entire physical
organism I mean I I'm not freezing or
whatever that would be and and again I'm
not in authority on that that kind of
doesn't pass my sniff test but I think
moreover the bigger picture here is
people so afraid of leaving the Earthly
life so believing that Earthly life is
is all that they are and and all that
they can be I think if they knew what
the overwhelming consistent message is
and near-death experiences that our
physical life isn't who we really are it
isn't the end that what we are who we
are is that Eternal infinite
Consciousness that goes on living after
our physical death here on Earth yeah so
tell me about some of that because so so
yeah that's an area we haven't really
gotten into what are people saying
because these are people that they came
back right so they didn't go you know
they either didn't get accepted or
whatever right now we're not judging
them you know there's tons of
applications right you know the
afterlife gets countless applications
every day these are interviewees who it
feels like got over there right and
that's funny I mean there's actually
been a study we uh that was someone went
through literally over a thousand of our
near-death experiences and when people
are say over you guys you mean yeah are
we are the ones we have posted when I
say we've studied over 4,000 near-death
experiences those are posted on our ND
are all the ones you get posted or not
all of them every single one that gives
us permission which is way over 95% is
posted but man you don't have any
there's no like let's make sure let's
have there's no protocol for you guys to
like be like come on this one didn't you
know this one has walking Phoenix in it
you know like this one didn't it y I
have I the Integrity of the research I
do requires that no matter what the
content of the near-death experience if
it appears to have occurred during a
life threatening event you know
sometimes I'll you know unless it's
blatantly falsified I mean hey
we got two near-death experiences in a
row where they encountered Pamela
Anderson and there obviously some
teenage probably boys they were having a
good old time and boom boom okay I get
that that's fake and that's rare thank
goodness because again it just takes too
long to do that but we have I have a
whole write up on how we very carefully
validate these near-death experiences as
real I understand we have a
responsibility to the world to make sure
that we have posted valid experiences
because other researchers are using this
interestingly artificial intelligence
has gone through the internet and that's
one of the major drivers of artificial
intelligence understanding of near-death
experience is the over 4,000 we have
posted right so you guys have so many of
them that obviously people are using it
but yeah I was just trying to get if
there's any barrier to entry between
your site so there is some if there's
some if people are saying Pamela
Anderson or Samuel Jackson or whatever
you're like I don't know you know yeah
so the the Integrity that of the
research we do is such that there's some
Integrity there's well there's a lot of
Integrity but there's some barrier to
entry well not really if they if I mean
this is less than 1% of people that have
shared what we consider to be obviously
falsified experien so it's it's I mean
it's rare with that order of but you
take some down that are obviously
falsified well it's not we will and
sometimes we learn we will post it and
then subsequently as they and again
these are usually people that have a
commercial interest in their account and
as time goes on we may come to
understand that they falsified
embellished their account using you guys
absolutely and they're out of there if
that happens so that again that's rare
and that says a lot about the Integrity
the of humans in general I mean people
that have a near-death experience that
is in general the most amazing
influential experience of their life
sacred to them yeah okay so so that's
interesting so people say it's to them
you know um what are some yeah what are
some of the things if people go there
they're on death's doorstep and they get
to come back you know nobody was home
they knocked they got some information
maybe you know uh but what is some of
the things that they what what do we
have you learned anything about the
afterlife I guess or that that next step
have you learned anything about that or
do you feel like you've learned anything
absolutely I am extremely interested in
that after years of doing research and
being aware that they were remarkably
consistently describing unearthly you
know Heavenly Realms obviously as a
researcher I'm danged interested in that
so in our most recent version of the
survey we've got a lot of questions
where I try to drill down on that try to
understand more about that remarkably
consistent perspective on what lies
Beyond death's door and that's where
Theo it gets dang interesting one thing
we're okay talk interesting here so
what's it like okay you know here it
first of all you have to understand it's
radically different from that physical
Earthly like that we know it's nothing
like a separate geographically
independent we have five senses dude
yeah oh yeah you know how many senses
you get probably when you're done here
well more you know there's 12 senses I
bet okay think about all the other
senses you could have the more the
merrier I know but regarding what I'm
consistently seeing based on survey
questions and and spontaneous comments
that they have the afterlife again
completely non-physical emotions
non-physical
communication uh they typically have a
greatly accelerated Consciousness they
often have amazingly what they call
Universal knowledge it's a sense of
knowing everything it's a bigger picture
of knowledge far more than they could
have known in their Earthly life now see
some of that relate makes me sound a
little bit like um you know I did a a
little bit of DMT with this guy from a
smoothie shop right okay you know and
that's uh it was in it was in uh I think
it was Maui basically yeah and hell it
might have been their damn um you know I
think the guys on their pamplet or
whatever you look at the Maui the you
know he's yeah anyway so uh but I
remember
thinking that all of my feelings were so
limited the the the the yes my concept
my concept of
existence that I had here on Earth was
kindergarten compared to what else there
was anyway when you said that that's
just that's just all I you know I
remember that and that's fascinating
glad you shared that I think there's
sort of different ways you can come to
understand that what we know all the
knowledge we have here on Earth is
incredibly small compared to that bigger
picture the if you call Universal
knowledge in fact near-death
experiencers become aware of basically
they'll describe as
understanding the universe how it all
fits together how it's connected that
drove me nuts when my early years of
research I kept saying we'll share
something bring back something we can
use in our Earthly life and I'll check
you right here because this reminded me
it's not that you get the knowledge that
the knowledge is like read to you as if
you read it on a page and then you know
the facts it's that the knowledge is
suddenly in you yeah that's what it
feels like you've got it bingo I just
realized that I'm always yeah it's like
it's not like you can you don't just
you're like it's not like go
everything's revealed to you really it's
just revealed in the sense that suddenly
you know it or that the the revelation
of it didn't even matter and that I
can't even explain it again now but but
exactly you're going right down the path
that I've heard from so many near-death
experiencers I love it what they will
become aware of is it it's funny they
often say it's so simple it's so easy
well gosh not those of us on Earth but
you know what's interesting after years
of studying these accounts and wondering
why they didn't bring back something
that we can use one near-death
experiencer taught me and said hey it's
like an ocean of knowledge he was aware
of and that can't fit into the teacup of
our human brain and then I went oh I get
it that's how limited we are in our
Earthly physical life right I've thought
about that before too that I wonder if
we just don't have the
means as limited as we are yes to to e
just and there's nothing wrong with that
it's just we're doing a great job we do
a ton of you know seeking and wondering
but even our ability to wonder is in not
infantile because here we are discussing
it but it's uh it's not able to know
exactly to be known and it's probably
good that it isn't because we would
really Wilt I think if we almost knew
and I think that's true I will tell you
the awareness of this Universal
knowledge that's out there that we don't
know one thing that that has led me to
consider in my research is Theo that's
just dang humbling I'm a doctor I'm a
smart guy blew through Premed my work in
three years so I I thought I was pretty
good but aware of this incredible
knowledge that is far beyond anything I
or anybody on Earth could understand is
really really humbling about how little
we really know in the big in the big
picture of things and it's kind of nice
if you can Embrace that yeah oh takes
the edge off well it tells there's a lot
that we all need to learn and uh that's
that kind of continues the scientist in
me saying okay we're still uh we haven't
got all of knowledge figured out there's
just a vast Universe out there just
waiting to be understood and discovered
and that's exciting we will we ever get
it but and maybe we will and maybe you
know and some of it is even us thinking
about this together and having
conversations like this you know and
comparing somebody who's done a lot of
research with people who weren't under
the influence of drugs unless you
consider like somebody being you know
falling off a cliff a drug or whatever
being in a car accident but um and then
somebody who's only had kind of unique
experiences through drugs you know um
and realizing that there's some
similarities and and some like that are
totally different what are some things
that people talked about the afterlife
the one thing you said that was
interesting was being able to make a
decision maybe to come or to go so
there's some like it's almost like do
you want to stay do you want to try this
new thing you know uh that's interesting
what else well you know what interesting
what's interesting Theo is that when
they're in that realm when they're in
that beautiful unearthly realm feeling
love and peace beyond anything the new
on their Earthly life that's not
unfamiliar they often say this is a
strong sense of their real home and and
not their Earthly life and that's one
reason they want to stay there they know
their friends family and loved ones that
they leave behind are going to be okay
that they too will be in that realm when
their time comes feeling you get to when
you hug somebody that you love I think I
like that I like that a lot and that
exactly that feeling it's almost it's
not even about the you're happy that
it's them you know but it's really not
even for there's a little bit of
sometimes in a moment in a hug where
it's not even about them it's just about
this like other little space that gets
created kind of that just feels uh
absolutely welcoming you know I'm
talking about kind of yeah I love
talking about love so we'll focus on
that but yeah when you've got a hug and
you've got that intense sense of love
you can understand in personal
experience the words in the dictionary
that it's like a connection like a unity
and you often can feel that and because
the love described in near-death
experience is one of the most common
words you see that the in the afterlife
described in near-death experiences one
of the most consistent themes amazingly
is they do feel that and they use a
stronger word the connection much more
commonly saying it's a Unity it's a
Oneness of of us and of everyone it's
sort of like the super if you will Ultra
love is what our destiny is going to be
in the afterlife oh yeah that 70s love
baby you know cuz the 2020s love is a
little you know it's
definitely it's got uh it's been I think
it's been cut with something you know
probably baby powder I'm guessing but I
you know I think it's definitely
different but that 70 stuff that sh that
was some pure love it seemed like back
then um oh
one thing that stood out in your book I
remember reading that
um that there was a that there that
blind people had similar near-death
experiences absolutely people of sight
that is a very good point Theo uh I
interviewed Vicki Vicky was born totally
blind oh wow she's really all in oh to
Vicki Vision was unknown and unknowable
I interviewed her and you know you
simply cannot explain Vision how how we
see in terms of the remaining other four
senses imp possible and so I Lear a
great uh game show they like a Japanese
game show you know that would be
interesting we had a beautiful young
Blind Lady will you bring bring her up
we had a blind woman that came on here
and we learned about being blind oh
fascinating it was really really
interesting that's great I interviewed
Vicky Vicky she was uh very good at
singing she was a professional singer so
she was singing in a bar one evening
which is what she did and was involved
in a terrible Auto accident and I'm
going to jump in on what you and many
other are thinking wait a minute she's
blind no she wasn't driving okay she had
an inebriated Patron driving which was
not a good idea so bash also if you're
drunk and you the last person you need
to help you get home is a blind person
yeah that she was probably not real
helpful with navigating down yeah it's
just like and let them be dude they're
doing their own thing you're drunk
driver yeah very at Le you know take
somebody that can see yeah well sorry
whatever well you know that's that just
shows you know exactly the problem of
drunk driving because he nearly killed
her of course he is like yeah and you're
like and you're like oh I'm so drunk at
least if we get in an accident this
person won't even see what happened you
know so they can't lie to the cops too
yeah there you go for you know that's
just the [__] that guy was probably
thinking probably well anyway so Vicki
was taken to the emergency room and the
first time in her life that she had
Vision she was in what we've talked
talked about that out of- Body
Experience Consciousness over her body
and you it's interesting to understand
her first emotional reaction of suddenly
having Vision which was unknown and
unknown to her she was actually
frightened because the sense of vision
was so unfamiliar she was initially
horrified what is this new sensation and
she had to actually calm down and then
finally correlated she didn't even know
who that was down on the gurnie below
but it was only after Vicky correlated
the feel of her long hair man I can't do
that well uh because I don't have long
hair but Vicki did so if you need it she
correlated a feel of her long hair and
interesting ring that her father had
given her she only knew by the sense of
feel and now she was seeing it from up
above in an out of Body Experience so
when she calmed down she then had a
tunnel experience had a review of her
life that Life review and went on into
those unearthly Heavenly realm's
beautiful highly detailed and highly
visual near-death experience but with a
Twist Theo her vision as she was
explaining it to me was what we hear
from many people that have near-death
experiences it's so-called 360 degree
Vision amazingly she's simultaneously
understanding Vision in front of her
behind her right left up down the proper
term would actually be like spherical
and that was the vision she knew so when
I told Vicki that those of us on our
Earth life have these pie-shaped visual
Fields because of where our eyes are in
the skull Vicki laughed at me she said
that just can't be she didn't get it
couldn't grasp it because her whole life
experience with vision was that
spherical Vision wow wow that's so
fascinating and then she came back here
and didn't have any more Vision she yeah
so when she returned to her Earthly body
Vicki was back to being totally blind
and I mean this is pure blindness no
sense of light no partial Vision at all
I mean this is like to her vision
unknown and unknowable interestingly and
I asked her did you see colors well how
could she answer that she had no life
experience of knowing what color is she
say but she knew she'd seen which is it
almost makes you believe that there's
just a one sense then it's a holistic
sense so then what why I wonder why we
get stuck here in these that these
entities that only have five senses then
we we almost feel like a SP split end of
you ever seen like a split end of hair
like you know like when we get they
split ends hairs or something and their
hair it looks like it's been doing drugs
or it's rattled you know it's had had
it's not been doing that well yeah and
uh and so um that's how I feel something
like a human where this erratic or if
you see a live wire on the ground and
it's just it's not connected but it's
like you know just that's how I feel
like humanity is where this split end of
existence that's that's frayed kind of
from what it seems like even nature is
supposed to like nature even though it's
violent and it's beautiful it's
everything at the same time it's
decaying it's birthing it's like this um
it's um it's constantly occurring right
it's and we sometimes feel like this
weird thing that's able to stick our
head out of Nature and just look around
at it right we don't know what we're
really grasping we're trying our best
some of us are you know wearing driving
gloves and thinking we're neat but most
of us are just like [__] dude we
don't know what's going on here anyway I
don't if that makes any sense but yeah I
think it does I think it shows like you
know here we're so used to our five
Earthly senses and yet in so many ways
they're limited I mean you hear these
accounts like Vicki and you go wow our
senses uh in the afterlife are going to
be much much more than we possibly knew
here I mean it's it's just really
breathtaking to think about how
Consciousness functions we're not
limited by who we are what we are in our
Earthly life I mean we're stuck with our
vision our hearing sensation you know we
got five senses and that's it you know
at least for most of us those yeah and
there's some pretty door to door senses
they're nothing real you know they seem
like kind of over the- counter senses
under the counter which one's the which
one you got to get a prescription for
yeah I like they're kind of uh kind of
they can be marginal I mean medically
you know we see people that have
impairment in their senses and that's
that's very very sad so but which one
you have to get drugs for which one do
you have to get a prescription for over
the counter or under the counter oh over
the counter is oh so these are under the
counter senses these are just like basic
you know like your regular Shel senses
you know on the Shelf senses yeah
nothing special it doesn't feel like
anything special yeah and and yet you
know it's all we got to live on it's
well shoot I guess one way of looking at
it Theo it's kept us alive for all of
our lives I'm not I'm grateful for but I
think when we start to look at Vicky's
sense even a blind person coming back
and saying look dude you guys can have
your vision or whatever BS you do
whatever two-dimensional BS you guys are
looking around and stuff that's fine
just knowing on that next level that you
get all the uh you know you get like uh
all the all the you get everything that
they have exactly I we're not limited
you know what I think too sometimes Dr
long is like I used to have this theory
that like um four-legged animals right
they complete a circuit right because
they're on the Earth right there's four
legs they complete a circuit and then us
somehow we ended up two we're two-legged
so we kind of have these Loose Ends all
the time and I feel like we're we're
we're just this uncompleted circuit
sometimes and that's sometimes how I
think why
we that's something that happened to us
we're we're maybe supposed to be more
four-legged because you look at some
two-legged animals kangaroos I think are
two-legged and they are yeah they're
obtuse brother they're they're bouncy
yeah they're fighting they have children
on them they're just like us really
they're like us at Disney World you know
and it's like so that's I that was a
theory I had like a year ago or
something that popped into my head I was
like why do we not fit sometimes with
nature at ease you know you know that's
an interesting point because you know
we're we're so much of nature is that
four-legged and and you it's fairly
consistent in terms of how animals go
around here we're the anomaly we're not
that's the thing we're the anomaly we're
not the norm we're the why did we end up
the anomaly and I and but then you start
thinking well is there a higher power
that wants us to be the anomaly that's
Tak us from this four-legged and stood
us up to have some Enlightenment which I
also think is very to me feels very uh
warm and wanting you know so um and it
could be a mix of the two I don't know
I'm just thinking out loud what have you
garnered from uh speaking with people
who have been close to the afterlife and
um what have you garnered from that oh
that's that's where my research gets
amazingly interesting what I'm seeing is
well Theo it's a basic scientific
principle that what's real is
consistently observed and that's where
it's exciting when you look at the
afterlife in near-death experiences
because what's described now times
thousands is so amazingly consistent I
mean it's a beautiful unearthly realm
that strong sense of peace and love but
off the scale beyond anything they knew
in their Earthly life um the encounters
with deceased loved ones interactions by
the way deceased pets are often
described in near-death experiences and
these are again joyous you know for
animal lovers out there tremendously
good news from near-death experiences I
mean hey Theo you name it dogs cats
birds horses I've seen not rats we pet
well I mean I haven't heard that but you
know certainly are are not it's not at
all unusual and like other deceased
humans that they knew these are joyous
reunions and you know sort of back to
that sharing like they did on Earth only
here they are in the afterlife so so do
they see that they see these people in
the afterlife what do people say they
physically see they see their father
cousin or grandparent or something they
see them in the way that they saw them
on Earth um not NE is there any
information about that you oh a lot like
how do people see people when they when
they have a near-death experience how do
former humans that they knew or humans
that they knew on Earth that are now
gone how do they see them in uh in the
ndes right they're essentially always
picture perfect health even if they died
of an Advanced age or a disfiguring
debilitating accident or injury when
they're encountered in the afterlife
they're essentially always absolutely
picture perfect health interestingly if
someone died in an extremely Advanced
age they may appear even decades younger
yes and if they died in very early
childhood amazingly they may appear in
older childhood really and so it seems
to be that kind of interplay usually
yeah usually they look pretty much you
know and they can tell
and another interesting thing you almost
never have people say Mary is that you
it's it's an immediate and intense deep
understanding that this is their beloved
they can share from issue you know what
they had and experienced in their past
life um there's a predisposition for
genetic relatives but you can be
anything obviously spouses or uh you
know pretty much it friends loved people
so it it again a beautiful beautiful
part of near-death experiences where you
have that joyous reunion and in fact
even if the Earthly life was strained in
the afterlife it's that's not an issue
anymore there's joyous sharing there can
be sort of like the analogous of of
interaction touch you can't really touch
non physical but there's certainly a lot
of that kind of very close sharing and
interaction a very beautiful very
touching part of near-death experience
so there's no like needing to get
overpass things everything's just equal
there yeah that I I I I that makes so
much sense man I think even I think
whenever I did some DMT or something my
feeling was just that these intricacies
the or these idiot these idiot ways that
we interact with each other and how we
treat each other it's all
so pointless to the a to what it all
whatever that value was at we're like
it's like there's a whole like equation
going on and we're over here like on a
um one of those Nimbus counters whatever
is it no that's a cloud but like one of
those like little you know that I don't
know I'm talking about dude Jesus Christ
but um but I do understand that I mean
it's it's it's like we're infantile in
understanding understanding that the
value of each other right and here we
have our Earthly things that separate us
those anger resentments jealousy and yet
none of that absolutely I wish everybody
on Earth could hear you say that for you
none of it matters when you're on the
afterlife because you're you're letting
go of all those things that that kept us
apart that separated on Earth and here
we are in the afterlife intensely
feeling unified connected one with
everyone and everything um literally you
know a concept of super love if you will
yeah so then why does this happen why
are we on this leg of Life do you think
do you able to grasp does anybody get
that sort of information or it doesn't
really go there it's just more of this
okay now I'm this there's the
opportunity when you die to get be
embraced into this everl this
Everlasting warm love all knowing place
but do they get any intel on why we're
in this realm now yes I asked a specific
survey question if during their
near-death experience they got any
specific information about the meaning
and purpose of life so Theo I've had
hundreds and hundreds of people give
that narrative response in direct answer
to that question and and what is
fascinating is that our Earthly life
first of all very important what we
learn here lessons about love
relationships what we experience is
important but way more important than we
could have possibly known it seems to
Ripple through an eternity and through
the lives Souls of many many other
people so um that was fascinating for me
to understand that as I kept getting
these narrative responses so there is
value to what we learn here that's what
you saying yeah oh absolutely there is
value and it's seems to be extremely
important and here's another concept
which a lot of people wouldn't think of
and that is you know all we know here is
our Earthly life I mean this just seems
to you sometimes drag on forever but our
real uh Consciousness our real beings is
that which is eternal and infinite this
physical Earthly life that we're living
seems to be the tiniest slice of our
Eternal existence this is literally the
one time during our Eternal existence
when we can know non- eternity non-
Infinity limitations what an interesting
way to think about it so that is that is
literally as opposed to trying to be
told or or learn from other people's
experience there is no other way for us
to learn all that we do in the physical
Earthly realm of life other than to
experience it right as a tiniest slice
of our infinite existence wow cuz yeah
you you think like man I want to get
back there where everything's
interesting but maybe when you're there
you're like dude we got to go back to
Earth where everything's all kind of
peac meal and weird and you got to
figure it out and you hit puberty or
whatever and [__] strange you know
absolutely I mean it's only during a
physical Earthly life I well the
afterlife you're not going to have that
anger you're not going to have that that
want you're not going to have you don't
even remember any of that oh yeah
absolutely it doesn't matter if you saw
somebody that you hated there's not even
the all of that friction or whatever
doesn't exist I don't think in the
afterlife well you've got that yeah but
the you've got that overwhelming sense
of love and compassion and connection I
mean you're really you think you would
forgive somebody or you don't even have
to forgive them it's just known it it's
I think it's a you there's one thing
that's overriding in the afterlife is
free will you have the free will choice
to forgive someone or not to forgive but
shoot that's what they say in the
afterlife well that's what we see from
many near-death experiencers describing
is grudge over there you you would have
I think if out of free will you would
have the ability to hold a grudge and
yet
I don't even know that I've seen any
near-death experiencers describe that in
other words this is completely off the
scale in terms of love peace that sense
of connection uh that sense that on our
Earthly life even if we made mistakes
and gez we all did oh yeah I know I did
oh I know that those referees who call
didn't call that pass interference about
six years ago when Drew Brees was in the
playoffs I know that they did talk about
mistakes I'm going to take that one of
the afterlife honestly you might have a
different perspective when you're in the
afterlife like you know I thought about
that I can let a lot of stuff go man but
those guy they just they should not have
done they should have figured that out
well anyway maybe I will you're right
I'm sorry but you have the choice you'll
probably have the choice to do that and
yet you'll understand that in a realm
where literally the guiding force is
love that that might not be loving and
so that might not be who you are at that
point in time and I think it's I know
it's it's it's tough to it's tough to to
put yourself in the mindset of that
infinite Eternal Beyond Earthly love and
unity that you have there but that's
what that's what I hear times thousands
no I look I I think uh I think that part
relates to feelings that I've had under
some psychedelics or under iasa just
this all know this this I can't remember
if it's iasa or DMT whichever it was
something I haven't done them in a long
time but um where it felt like yes all
this silly stuff of the the world world
this Earthly world didn't matter it's
but there but then there must be some
long-term thing to it but but like
you're saying it does it does matter to
be here and exist and go through this my
friend Megan sheii she's like a
therapist in Oregon and she's really a
really neat thinker and a deep thinker
and she um she would say sometimes that
some of our soul some Souls that you
come across and some of our souls and
maybe me and and maybe you and are like
baby Souls it's like their first time
doing uh the Earth show you know so some
some Souls you meet and they're just
like oh some of them have been here a
long time maybe and they're you know
they're smoking or whatever and they're
you know they're complaining outside of
the library but some of them it's their
their first time and they're like you
know having a blast or just I don't know
I thought that was kind of a interesting
school of thought that she shared with
me one time yeah it's a concept of old
souls you know I've heard of that before
right you've heard of that before I just
never heard of young I'd never really
thought of the the other side of it that
that's that it's some soul it's just
like they're fresh out of the B you know
the the the bassinet and they're just
you know well if you have old souls you
have young Souls together a binary but
again I think it's all you know in the
afterlife I I don't I don't know if
there's really a judgment or that it's
so critical I think we're all here to
learn um there you know we're all here
to share and interact with each other
and learn from those relationships and
grow from those relationships I mean
that's going to be a part of the
consciousness of who we are what we are
and and literally what we can share with
eternal Consciousness uh you know on an
ongoing basis so it's really that
important it's not just our
Consciousness it's what we can do as a
group it's what we can yeah it's
literally there's a shared Consciousness
there's a shared knowing and so that's
we talked about briefly earlier about
like a ripple effect of Consciousness so
what we do in our Earthly life the
choices we make the love that we express
is actually literally Rippling through
eternity far more important than we
realize than we we could possibly know
here I love that that's such a great
thought man it's such a great Theory too
and it's one that we need to put out
there more and I I I feel like um we're
getting more I feel like that is going
to become I think we're starting to
realize that these these ways of like
immense greed and like putting each
other at like massive amounts of people
at pain for profit and just and it just
there's no what is the long-term value
of it well anybody that think what is
the longterm value of oppressing a
people or of you know it's like we have
to be evolving out of that and it's like
I I I think a lot of us are starting to
see that like it does because the only
way we all have to be here and it's like
we ha you have to find a way where it
all works out you know and some of these
um archaic ideas of greed and of uh
just um I don't know I think about that
stuff a lot I I like that because after
all you know the old adage you can't
take it with you I mean if you spend
your life being greedy and hoarding and
and you know material possessions none
of that is going to exist in a physical
afterlife but what is going to be a part
of you your soul is going to be those
loving outreaches you had it's going to
be those times that you really showed
compassion and that is to be what helps
Define us our Eternal Soul and will
Ripple out and be a part of us forever I
agree with you and but we can do that as
a be I think our leadership and how we
choose to can do that like I I like I
don't know I I'm not like a socialist
really I don't think but I I guess I I
am a person that like that I believe
people should be capped on kind of the
amount of money that they can make I
don't believe that corporate like we
should I don't think we should sacrifice
the good good of PE the betterment
overall betterment of people and of your
experience on Earth uh
for technological advancement for profit
I don't I like I don't know I haven't
fully conceptualized some of my ideas
and I don't know what they are but I
just see how it just makes it sick it's
like we could just we could have better
lives overall it feels like but then
maybe part of the reason that we're here
is to have this struggle and to see
these things and to know what um
what the ups and downs feel like and to
know what it feels like not to care
about each other as much as we should
you know so then when you do go to that
other place it's like oh this makes so
much sense you nailed it it's the
struggle we're having struggles here all
of us you know the needs the wants the
the you know the the thinking that we
should be greed you know the the the
desires we have to you know struggle
with just being human I wonder if we do
better do we Evol like wonder if we if
at a certain point we do like decent
good enough then God gives us another
sense like now you got this sense boys
and you're like whoa bro so I wonder if
we can evolve if we all got to a level
of of caring about each other or of
doing something you know and I know that
[__] sounds kind of Hoy toyy and we are
the world and Magic Johnson or whatever
or Michael Johnson molested those kids
or whatever I'm not saying all that but
I'm just saying like if we all got to a
level where we could like could we like
do we get to go to another level if we
can beat this level on Earth absolutely
I think that's a a beautiful statement
of a hope of a vision for Humanity if we
can all learn about the importance of
love compassion sharing um let go of
those all to human greed once uh you
know the incredible dispares in M
material Goods around the world which is
just incredible if we could let go of
that if we could all know that we are
one we are one world world one people if
we could just visualize that work
towards making it happen absolutely we
as a Humanity could evolve and evolve in
a very positive direction and we would
yes and I think that that is a great
expression of hope so good I like your
attitude too Dr long and look obviously
I'm sitting here in a warm room and you
know clothes and food and everything I'm
not like trying to
uh but at the same time I'm not going to
burn down every
moment of my own life or like
achievement or something just to try and
say that that idea isn't possible you
know it's like obviously we're
privileged enough to be able to say that
you know or whatever you know we have
microphones we have what you know we
have electricity and everything um and
yet here we are you know talking about
you know being able to talk about this
and and yet we're we're learning about
the importance of these values from
near-death experiences from our own
lives I mean it's that seed of
compassion that I think every human
being has it's just a matter of bringing
that out helping people to manifest that
and how it would change the world if if
we all understood that and different
ethnicities different places different
people they have less of it than others
I think different people we all have
different pieces of each other's lock
you know like we're all the keys to each
other's locks that's what my friend
James Basher always says and it's like
we're all like different you know we do
need each other anyway this is getting a
little bit like preachy almost but not
it's it's positive
and it's good it's a good Mage and I
don't mean that but I don't want to get
to the point where we sound like we're
just like we know like we're trying to
save the world the this hope of yeah and
yet the Hope For Humanity that we are
expressing very directly here is
directly part of the near-death
experience wisdom over and over we're
understanding those Concepts and that's
directly relevant to the the greater
truth the greater understanding and
literally the hope for world that people
that have Near Death exper experiences
bring out yeah now what about this dude
they say what's if somebody's going to
die and they're not going to do
near-death experience they're just going
to die right what's what should you wear
you think if you're going to
die cuz like so you get so because some
people say you know sometimes sometimes
I think that if you whatever you wear
you dying you could get that job in the
afterlife they say dress for the job you
want you know what I'm talking about um
Theo yeah in 25 years of interviews like
this that's the first time I've heard
this question so I'll address that I
don't think it makes beans worth of
difference what you're wearing or what
you're not wearing or nothing at all I
mean it it's in the afterlife it's going
to be your Consciousness not your
clothes it's not going to be any aspect
of who we are physically uh clothes hair
uh you know jewelry we're wearing you
know we are much more than that we are
Consciousness and that's that's what
near-death experiencers are consistently
describing as going on to the afterlife
yeah I think I'm GNA wear a chef's hat
probably cuz I uh I would want to be in
a bakery I think if I'm in heaven and
you're in a bakery imagine how good it
smells you know would be good and you're
just making scones or whatever cuz the
British I guess get to go to heav you're
making me hungry yeah Heavenly scones I
don't believe you know I don't believe
everybody should be there but I'm you
know all right but they're British
they're good folks but you know some
people don't think that they are yeah
but um have you have you this is one
last question I have for you Dr long and
thank you so much for your time today
man pleasure I'm glad this evolved I
think we stayed patient with each other
and this evolved into a cool
conversation this is an awesome
conversation so carry on what you got
there yeah and I'm grateful to this book
man I'm I'm grateful just like you know
that there's somebody who wants to care
enough to think about this and collect
this information because it's it's kind
of tedious I'm sure it is my literally
my second full-time job and a big shout
out to my wife jod she is a licensed
attorney and yet she stepped down from
doing that so she could devote full time
to running the website and working to
this information and share it back with
the world the experiences the near-death
experiences shared with us freely it's
wonderful that we have the opportunity
to share them back freely uh literally
in over 30 different languages so people
all over the world can read these if you
go to the website nf.org go to the
homepage you'll quickly realize yeah we
don't have anything for sale and we
don't solicit donations why but that
doesn't seem like the typical
materialistic Viewpoint it's because we
know that the information we have the
experiences we're sharing are so
important we don't want to compromise
the Integrity of that by having any
commercial interest right on the
homepage okay got it that's fair I
respect that man I think there's
certainly ways to do that sort of thing
and and there's ways also not to feel
embarrassed about it you know like I
think from listening to you I don't I
think I can people's instincts usually
are what they are and everybody will
make their own decision as to if
somebody thinks you're some sort of a
snake oil salesman or something but
that's not what I gathered um
and and we do that for everyone you know
we do that on all types of things I'll
tell you this I accidentally bought four
copies of the book and one audio copy of
evidence of the afterlife because uh
yeah I had I didn't know where I was
going to be and so I um if I was going
to be here La so I bought one and then
uh my friend got me one and then I
bought an audio uh copy as well but I
don't have God in the afterlife this is
a different book yeah that came out
later and that's where we went into the
deeper if you will spiritual content of
near-death experiences concepts of God
which I want to hasten to add many
near-death experiencers say God is a
human word and what they encountered in
God is far beyond human language far
more uh you know they would are
concerned about being Limited in what
they encountered by using typical
English verbal expressions of that which
is beyond the verbal Beyond language and
God but also great deal of writing in
this book about love and the concept of
that that seems to be if you will the
glue that holds the universe together
and what we've alluded to earlier uh the
overwhelming consistent comments from
people that have been in that unearthly
Heavenly realm that amazing concept that
we're all one we're all unified we're
all together uh and forever which is
again completely different from
conventional Western religious thinking
and yet by the literally at this point
thousands we have people that have
near-death experiences sharing that yeah
yeah no I think uh that that's
interesting so people so that one's a
little bit more of a religious aspect
this has nothing to do with religion
this is purely evidence based this is
purely what people have okay their
experience of what of any interactions
with what they perceive to be God and
you're saying that overall that
experience was that the god that they
perceived or the energy of a higher
power or of an more all- knowing power
was greater than something we could
actually conceptualize and the best we
can do with that here on Earth is by
saying God absolutely is just the most
common word I mean you know there's
really no
other senses it goes to the senses of
this is the best we can do with the five
senses we have is create this um this
this uh lower level according now if we
if we believe in this higher level that
of uh of communication and of sharing
and an idea of something yeah absolutely
yeah that's you got it you nailed it
there Theo thanks dude it only you know
it only took us 2 hours to do it so what
about have you have you had anyone who
had a near-death experience from like a
um a uh like a
mass like a 911 or a school shooting or
a mass death type of scenario was there
anything like that ever I know you said
there was one where there was two people
yeah have you had anybody report from
something greater like that wow you
that's a good question you know
fortunately Mass sudden death mass
shootings Mass things like that are very
very rare you know virtually all people
that die it's going to be you know their
individual death that accident illness
Advanced age that kills them I can't
right off the top of my head think of
any near-death experiences that occurred
at a time of a a very Mass death that
have been shared with but I'll sure keep
my eyes out for one yeah I'm just
wondering if there's too much death in
one moment at that place for the other
side to like really you know maybe they
have to just um
you know maybe they don't have as much
of a intake you know person working that
day or whatever where you have enough
time with them you know what I'm saying
you don't I don't know where you know
because I imagine that some things would
be a little bit similar maybe they just
like all right everybody get in here you
know you can't loyer you know yeah uh I
don't think we have to worry about that
the every hint of information about the
afterlife is overwhelmingly more
intelligent loving and I think there's
an
immediate sort of wear entry into the
Afterlife for anybody who's permanently
deceased on this world any celebrities
have reached out to you any interesting
folks like that or like people you know
that any like interesting folks that
have reached out to you to be more
curious about your work yeah we we do
periodically here for some I mean you
name it doctors Executives uh some
people that don't want their name
mentioned but yeah we've had some people
very interested in this that have
contacted me you know like are you sure
Dr long are do you really be how what is
the evidence behind it can you share it
with me so we've I've banded with some
people uh way up the food chain if you
will uh in this society that are are
fascinated with this research and want
sort of a one-on-one perspective so yeah
I've done that there there's plenty of I
mean how can you not be fascinated about
what happens after you die and so you
know people that are you know well Todo
that famous literally have those same
interests that I think everybody does
certainly at least some point in their
life yeah well it's a big conversation
that we have about death and it's a lot
of times it's a conversation I think
that we have with ourselves but that
we're really afraid to have absolutely
you know I don't know how much I have a
conversation with myself about death and
if I do what even is it really yeah like
what do you know anything about that
it's such an unknown is such a mystery
oh I I think just about every person
that's ever walked this planet you like
you have thought about this and and it's
unknown or unknowable the good news is
interestingly when people have a
near-death experience as you might guess
their fear of death drops dramatically
from a person who's had a near-death
experience these are called After
Effects the typically observe changes
after a near-death experience and one of
the most common is a dramatic reduction
in their personal fear of death and
that's no surprise now is it they know
what lies Beyond death's door because
they personally experienced it they know
it's wonderful and not to be feared yeah
man that reminds me whenever I did that
DMT man I remember I called my mother
after after I sent her a text and I said
hey M don't worry about getting older or
dying it's not that big of a deal what
we're doing here isn't as super
important as we think it is and that
everything's going to be way awesomer
than you think it is um which is just
interesting because that's the only time
I think maybe that DMT experience was a
little bit more like some of the
near-death experience but I'm going to
go and read I'm going to go check out
that website and and see what more
information I can Garner because this is
really just it's neat to think about MH
but man yeah get close now are there
people
who want to sign up and say hey put me
under some type of a coma or something
so I can try to have a near-death
experience are they kind of like
astronauts of death where they want to
go into that darkness and see what they
can get and come back are there people
like that yeah fortunately people that
have raised that possibility for having
themselves have an induced death is
first of all it's vanishingly rare thank
goodness second of all nobody nobody's
ever going to do that that would be
illegal unethical and that's not how you
study near-death experiences I mean
shoot look at this we've had thousands
of people share their near-death
experiences why should we put someone's
life in jeopardy to just study what we
can ask literally thousands tens of
thousands probably around the world
millions of people that have had
near-death experience so there's
absolutely nobody's going to do that
right I see it from your side especially
as a medical professional right but are
there I'm dude I bet we could damn do
sign up online you know I bet you get
six people off Twitter by midnight today
who would do it you know who would let
you put them under some sort of a thing
and they would sign that you know the
you know the Red Rover agreement or
whatever if they don't come back or
whatever I don't know what it would be
called but I bet we could I bet there's
a lot of people who'd be like
near-death uh experienc astronauts or
whatever who would want to just you know
every other day maybe they maybe it's an
every other day job you put them in a
coma or something and say see what Happ
they try to come back around yeah sadly
that's true I think there's a lot of
people that so want to to incorporate
that that wonderful message of
near-death experience into their own
life that they would be willing to risk
it again illegal unethical and
absolutely not a self-loving path which
we see in near-death experiences so
commonly that overwhelming importance of
love that's not loving either to
themselves or to the individuals would
put them in a dying State that's it's
really it's sort of like the lessons we
learned from people that had near-death
experiences as a result of suicide
attempts they learned vividly that
that's not the right thing to do it was
a huge mistake
right wow man this is this pretty this
is pretty heavy here Theo this but you
don't have a lot of talks where things
get this deep no and it's nice though I
want to have more talks like this and I
think you know even us just talking
about some of these things like I want
to have more talks about like greed and
why do we live in this space because I
think some of the sickness that we feel
as humans these days that we like you
know there's a lot of emotional
unwellness and mental unwellness and I
think a lot of it is just because of a
we realize or we feel and we can't even
maybe put words to it sometimes that
we're sick
of something we've created a way of
being a way of treating each other and
even some of us are at fault we're all
part of it but we're sick of it I think
we're it's making us sick we are all
stuck in it kind of and we don't and
we've never been able to see it before
but I think we're starting to be able to
see it a little bit does that make any
sense to you or am I crazy no absolutely
I like what you're saying I think
there's you know there's sort of that
sickness innate in humanity I mean here
we are you know self-focused uh focused
away from other people uh focused on our
own interests and our own concerns our
own wealth or own everything I mean it's
literally you're getting down to values
there's a sickness in the expression of
values all around the world today and
that's a sad thing it's you know
globally you could call it unloving and
yet here in near-death experiences is
that consistent message pointing to
that's not the way that's not how life
is to be lived you need to think about
your neighbor you need to think about
other people you need to reach out
compassionately I mean it's literally a
profound message of Hope for all of
humanity and in fact these profound deep
messages and the near-death experience
are in my opinion the most profoundly
positive message even conceivable for
all of humanity wow it's crazy that we
have to almost die to get a message of
how to live you know that we have to go
you know we have all this life in front
of us every moment in front of our eyes
and you have to go that close to the you
know to that white vulture of the Lord
Death and and go over there and feed
them bird seat out of your dang hand
it's just get a little bit of
information from it and yet I think we
need to if we do understand that that's
the big picture that that's really a
part of our real Eternal and infinite
existence and that we're all here to
learn lessons to move closer to that
greater reality that we have that Unity
that love that compassion I mean I think
that sets you know really a pathway that
we can all think about each day of our
daily lives and maybe move one step
closer to being our true selves which is
what we're going to be in the afterlife
right yeah man it's defin definitely uh
it's definitely super fascinating it's
interesting to think about I'm grateful
that God let me exist to even kind of
just get to think about stuff like this
that's some sometimes the most
fascinating thing about life and
especially of being able to stay alive
and get older because you get to see
more concepts of like that's one of the
saddest things I think when people die
young is they just don't get to see like
how things kind of a little bit more
clarity you get and and a little bit
more light knowledge you get of what of
of of existing and stuff yeah absolutely
was there anything else I was going to
ask you about man you this has been a
great interview so yeah you've really I
mean you've really covered a lot of
material here very fascinating I love
this different perspective that you're
bringing out in this discussion here uh
I think you're coming at the concept of
near-death experiences in a very special
and I think very important very positive
way it's sort of that you need to think
about near-death experiences are are
such a a all-encompassing we start
talking about infinite and eternal
Consciousness and our s for Souls I mean
literally just coming at the concept of
near-death experiences from so many
different ways I have learned in this
discussion here I've thought about
things I I haven't really thought about
before so this has been great this has
been very helpful to me personally and
I'm sure to vast number of viewers as
well oh thanks man yeah well I think
it's you know yeah I just feel grateful
that we got to chat about it dude
honestly um you know it's nice to think
about it and it's nice to be just
reminded about it you know m it's
interesting the things that we focus on
and listen to and stuff do have an
effect on how we feel and think and
stuff you know I think sometimes yeah
uh yeah I think it's important you know
where we put our attention you know and
the dark arts have really masterminded
ways to take our attention and use it
for evil I don't think they know they're
doing it for evil they think there
there's other reasoning behind it but we
just have to be careful where we put our
attention you know that's the most
important thing it's hard and I'm not
preaching about it I suff just like
everybody else but to recognize that we
suffer is kind of a or that we're that
where we're trapped a little bit is is
kind of interesting and good start
that's really cool man what a neat hobby
that turns into something
fascinating when you look back on that
part of it like your own attention to it
and stuff what uh what gifts has it
given you out of paying attention to it
absolutely I have been profoundly
affected by my study of near-death
experiences as a physician and I'm
practicing fulltime this has helped me
to be much more compassionate focused on
the patients loving to them literally
going the extra mile really being the
kind of a doctor to my patients that I
would want a doctor to be with me and in
fact in the facility that I'm working at
now patient satisfaction is measured by
a national survey called press gainy for
the past seven months the facility I'm
working in yeah I've heard of that
before you've heard of press gainy well
how about about you probably haven't
heard of this in the last seven months
of the press G any surveys in the
facility I'm working with every single
patient that was surveyed on every
single question we were at the 99% level
based against national standards but
again it shows and I want to emphasize I
contributed to that by the compassion
and love and attention and focus I give
patients but that's a whole dang team
that shares that value of compassion
doing their best of of making patients
feel like you know it's their home away
from home when they come in there that
they're really being cared for each
person is an individual so between me
and the whole team there we have some of
the highest patient satisfaction scores
you're going to find anywhere Theo well
that's congratulations and and and no
that's that's awesome that your own work
has ended up uh that your own hobbies
and interests have ended up inspiring
you to do your original job better it
really um with press gainy we had a
corner in and he was talking about once
press gainy they started a calling
people and asking them to rate how
they're experien right right that it
started to affect that somehow the
opioid those makers use the press gainy
press gainy scores and the that the
opioid makers were using the press gainy
to somehow do you know what I'm talking
about it all yeah unfortunately uh I am
suspicious that you know patients that
were seeking narcotics and then would
get that would rank their healthc care
team higher than if their health care
team did proper medicine and didn't give
them inappropriate opioid so I I I hope
that's not what this is but I I have a
fe I I just remembered literally when
you said that I this the only second
time I've ever heard it go back to the
top please it says uh the US has get to
the
writing the US has been in the middle of
an opioid crisis for the past decade
death uh more than 150 people a day die
from opio we know all that stuff in an
interesting angle researchers have been
looking if there's a direct or indirect
link between press gainy course and the
opio crisis press gy is a company that
has the healthcare industry's largest
database of patient caregiver and
physician feedback which you're saying
you guys have done a great job with and
you think that a lot of that is because
of your also understanding of what
people's potential life after their life
on Earth is it has certainly helped me
to be a more compassionate uh courageous
doctor I mean I I deal with patients oh
these are people that are facing a
life-threatening illness cancer is a
scary word but with what I've learned
about near-death experiences I can
approach each patient with cancer in
their journey of treatment and hopefully
recovery and and cure with increased
hope with increased compassion um in a
way that I I I know uh is beyond what I
could have done before I started
studying near-death experience well yeah
if you're a concierge for this more
comfortable afterlife or existence even
just even if you just are collecting all
the rumors of it that's very fascinating
I think would definitely warm me if I'm
a someone who's really in severe pain I
mean it warms me and I'm not in pain
yeah um but yeah I just want to look at
this but patients using prescription
opioids to manage their pain are 32%
more likely to report High patient
satisfaction scores according to recent
research out of Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center but here's my question is
why if if a if a medical place gets a
higher press gaining score do they get a
is there a financial incentive to them I
mean not directly I mean I'm not
accusing you of anything I'm just you
just happen to be here when this is
happening I don't want you
I'm not I'm not yeah I I I haven't read
that study so I can't really comment on
the Dartmouth study and and you'd really
have to read it to to understand the
nuances to to Really interpret it I
think accurately but you know as the
study says that you know there's there's
probably many different reasons that
that people could could rate their think
get Healthcare team higher if they get
you know more opioids I'm on an opioid
damn I'll rate you know I'll rate my you
know I'll rate my neighbor's violent son
higher you know or what you know what
I'm saying I'll rate somebody parked in
my driveway higher and I don't even know
him you know but but it this says the
surveys promote an assumption that
patient satisfaction is an index of
physician competence but then what
hospitals can do is they can say we have
the highest score medical places because
yeah I was just C because I remember he
said that and I was like because he said
he thought some of the opioid crisis was
influenced more by some part of the
press gaining but I could I couldn't
understand what he was talking about and
so we didn't go down that road
when you said it it just me and and I'd
have to look over the study because
there's there's it's
multifactorial it's not a simple opioid
you know it's not it's correlated not
causal it could be for any medicine
really if we give more medicine to our
some of our clientele then they're some
places are hypothe hypo hypothesizing
well then they'll give us higher scores
and if we get higher scores then we can
say we're the best ranked hospital or
whatever in the area yeah I mean I'd
wonder about that I don't know if the
Dartmouth study made that point but
that's you know that's that's certainly
a concern I can't imagine that that who
I mean I guess if you make that much
money by being a higher ranked then
maybe it would be worth it to you to me
it doesn't seem like there's enough
juice for the squeeze really in it um
but anyway uh Dr Jeffrey long I
appreciate it man it maybe longer huh if
there's an afterlife oh yeah we we may
that's a good point uh this may not be a
do at the end of this discussion there
may be a continuity a sharing of
experience in an afterlife infinitely
and eternally so we may uh be encounter
each other again as Souls well nice to
get to know you here on uh here on the
starter block I like that but um thank
you so much for just aiding people in
their cancer Journeys and um and for
being somebody that's curious about
possibilities outside of just the form
of uh of modern medicine these days and
um I think that's really interesting for
people to hear and and uh and thank your
wife too for being a part of your life
as you guys have that's brought y'all
closer together in some ways and and
she's helped and it just seems
interesting and and I'm I'm glad that
you did all this work so that we could
think about it yeah well thank you great
interview we we covered some very
fascinating and informative uh Concepts
here so been an honor and a privilege to
hang out with you and talk about all
this this is great you bet man where can
uh and people we'll put links to your
stuff online and you are a practicing
physician yep fulltime dear
God I tried to retire and I failed went
back back to working full-time but heck
you know it's a labor of love just like
my work and near-death experiences I I
love doing both parts of both aspects of
My Life um thank you so much Dr long and
I wish you the best of luck thank you
appreciate it take care I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my I
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going
to